>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Well good
afternoon everybody and thank you
so very much for being
here today with us
in the African Middle East Division.
I am the Chief of the
Division Mary-Jane Deeb.
And I am delighted to
welcome you all here.
I know that you're here because of
the speaker, because of the topic,
because it's a fascinating topic.
Mona Khademi is going to
be talking on the life
of Laura Clifford Dreyfus Barney
and her connections
with Iran and Iranians.
And this lecture, this presentation
today is part of a lecture series
on Persian lecture series
that we've been holding
for the past four years.
It's been curated by the Persian
specialist Hirad Dinavari.
And it is a continuation if you
want, of the wonderful exhibit
that we had on 1,000
years of the Persian book.
So we are continuing on the themes,
on Persian themes and I always put
in a few words about our
own division and as most
of you already know our division
is made up of three sections,
the African, the Hebraic
and the Neri section.
We cover 78 countries in
the Middle East and African
and Central Asia and the Caucasus.
We collect materials in the
languages of those countries.
We collect, we preserve,
we serve these collections.
But we also want those
collections to be known by everyone.
And so we organize programs,
exhibits, conferences
and other activities that
highlight these collections,
and that inform our
patrons about the countries
and the cultures these
publications come from.
So our presentation
today is a case in point.
Mona Khademi is a scholar and
has been a patron at the library
for many, many years and has used
our collections extensively has
kindly agreed to discuss her work,
the work that she's currently
engaged in with us today.
And to share with us her research.
So I am grateful and delighted that
she's here and it is from scholars
like her that we all get to
know better the countries
that we are responsible
for that you come here
to use the collections from.
So, now to introduce
Mona Khademi is the head
of the Nirri section Joan Weeks.
[ Applause ]
>> Joan Weeks: Well
it's my great pleasure
to introduce our speaker today.
Mona Khademi is the Director
of International Arts Management
Consulting in Washington D.C.
Through her consulting firm she
has promoted global understanding
through the exchange of arts and
cultural programs for over 20 years.
Her areas of interest include
development and management
of international, cultural
and arts programs.
She is a member of the
American Alliance of Museums.
Khademi received her Master's
Degree in Arts Management
from American University, a
BA from Pahlavi University,
today's Shiraz University.
And is a PhD candidate in
Organizational Psychology
from the University of London.
She is also an independent
researcher and has presented papers
at conferences in Switzerland,
Italy, Spain, England
and several cities in the US
as well as at the association
of Iranian Studies and the
Middle East Studies Association
and conferences.
Her articles have been published
in several journals and magazines,
quarterlies and has chapters
of books both in English
and Persian promoting
Iranian cultural activities
in the Washington D.C. area has
been her focus for many years.
In addition, she has been carrying
out research about the life
of Laura Clifford Dreyfus
Barney since the year 2000.
And has presented papers and
published articles on the subject
and is currently writing a full
biography to be published soon.
So, it gives me great pleasure
to welcome Mona to the podium.
And we're very much looking
forward to her presentation today.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Mona Khademi: Thank
you very much.
It is my great honor to be speaking
at the Library of Congress today.
My gratitude goes to Dr. Mary-Jane
Deeb, the wonderful Director
of the Middle East Section of the
African and Middle Eastern Division
of the Library of Congress.
And Mary-Jane Weeks, and
Dear Hirad Dinavari for the -
for all the hard work he has done
for organizing today's event.
And my thanks go to each
one of you in the audience.
Thank you so much.
My challenge today has
been to prepare a talk
about the life of Laura
Dreyfus Barney.
And her long fruitful
life for a limited time.
For the interest of
time and in order not
to miss any important points
I will read my presentation.
I will be showing some
historical pictures and I would
like to ask you not to take
any pictures of the images
because they are copyrighted.
The first question people ask
me always is why did you become
interested in Laura Barney's life?
It was in the year 2000 when
I heard that studio house
at 2306 Massachusetts Avenue,
Northwest was being sold
and its contents auctioned.
Studio House was the
house that Laura Barney
and her sister Natalie
Barney had inherited
after the death of their mother.
And then years later in 1960 donated
it to Smithsonian Institution.
The house which is on
the National Register
of Historical Places stands
currently and is owned and occupied
by the Embassy of Latvia.
A plaque with the name
of Laura and her sister -
Still stands outside the building,
acknowledging their donation.
I knew that Laura Barney was Bahai.
And that she had compiled a book but
did not know much more about her.
I visited the house at that
time and I got interested
to learn more about her life.
I found very little
published material and that is
when I started my journey.
A journey that I found fascinating
and has continued to date.
Research about her life has taken me
to a variety of archives in France,
England, Switzerland and
several cities in United States.
And I have found correspondences,
documents, newspaper articles
and I've even been able
to interview some people.
And the material that
I have found they were
in English, Persian and French.
And obituary in the Washington
Post in August of 1974 wrote
about Laura Dreyfus Barney.
And after writing about her family
and her achievements it reported
that her interests extended from
the International Council of Women
to local philanthropic
projects in Washington.
She had died on August 18 at her
home in Paris, she was 94 years old.
It said that Mrs. Barney was
a member of the Bahai faith
and wrote the book Some Answered
Questions, a book about her faith.
Who was Laura Barney?
Why do we have to know
about her life?
What are some of her
accomplishments?
How was her childhood?
Why did she learn Persian?
What attracted this privileged woman
to a faith emanating from Iran?
Where did she meet
Gandhi, Ezra Pound,
Whistler and Eleanor Roosevelt?
Why was she awarded and appointment
an officer of the Legion d'Honneur.
Why was this woman called a global
leader and who had noble deeds?
Today I will answer
some of these questions.
Laura Clifford Barney was
born in Cincinnati in 1879
to wealthy Albert Clifford
Barney who was an industrialist
and financier, who was the son of
a manufacturer of railway cars.
Her mother was Alice Pike Barney, a
prominent artist, a philanthropist
and the daughter of a
multi-millionaire entrepreneur.
Alice became a civic and
social leader in Washington
in the early twentieth century.
Albert and Alice had two
daughters, Natalie and Laura.
Laura who was born three
years after her sister.
The family moved to
Washington D.C. in 1889.
The sisters had the rich
and privileged life
and grew up in luxury.
The family's summer
vacation home had 26 rooms.
They had governess
and private tutors.
The two sisters were sent to a
private boarding school outside
of Paris, and then back to the US.
And the family attended
Episcopalian church.
The characters of the two sisters
were different from an early age.
Laura was the one who was diligent,
the student - a diligent student,
rather shy, who always tried to
improve and had serious thoughts.
From childhood, she
had the sense of duty.
Natalie was the opposite.
In 1900 when Laura had returned
to Paris to continue her education
in dramatic arts, she attended a
meeting at the home of May Bolles,
an American woman living in Paris.
May Bolles was among the first
group of Westerners who had gone
to visit the head of the Bahai
faith Abdul Baha in Akka, Palestine,
today's Israel, the year before.
Abdul Baha was the son of the
prophet founder of the Bahai faith.
Because of the time limitations
I will not talk about the history
of the Bahai faith, whose forerunner
was the Bab, its founder Baha Alla,
who was born in Iran 200 years ago.
And because of his teachings he
was exiled together with his family
and was imprisoned in Baghdad,
Adrianople, Istanbul and lastly
to the prison city of Akka.
Soon after that meeting with May
Bolles in Paris Laura traveled
with her cousin to Akka to meet
the spiritual leader from the East.
After a long and difficult trip.
After meeting Abdul Baha,
she realized that those were the
teachings she had been waiting for
and she became a believer
in the Bahai faith.
Laura's attraction to this
new faith were most likely
because of the principles
of equality between sexes
and the belief in the oneness
of God and oneness of humanity.
She returned to Akka
after a few months.
On her second visit,
Abdul Baha asked her
to accompany Abdul Fadl Gulpaygani
an Iranian scholar to the West.
Abdul Faz was the most rooted
and the greatest Bahai scholars
living in Egypt at that time.
She accompanied him to Paris with
a translator and after a stay
of three months she
accompanied him to the US.
Laura and her mother
paid for his expenses.
During his stay Laura deepened
her knowledge of this new faith
and started learning Persian.
In Washington Alice Barney,
Laura's mother had become interested
in the Bahai faith and its
teachings and held meetings
at her home for Abdul Faz.
She painted a portrait
of him which is now
at the Smithsonian National
Museum of American Arts.
There were always write ups about
the Barney family in the local
and even the national newspapers
given their social status.
An article in the Washington Post of
March 1902 read "Ms. Laura Barney,
who is a Bahai'st as
are other members
of Alice Clifford Barney's family,
says that at Akka one sees
demonstrated both in the family
and the religious life the
harmony and love which is one
of the pivotal principles of
the teachings of Bahai'ism".
And sometimes the news they covered
in the newspapers gave
incorrect information.
Laura was never amused, but this
was what she had to tolerate.
Gossip magazines printed
several untrue and false articles
about Laura's mother
and made fun of Laura.
Her father who cared about
people's opinion about his family
and their social standing was
not happy to see the articles
and he decided to close the house
where the meetings were held.
Another incident that
made him furious was
that the year before the news
of the publication of a book
by Natalie which had reached him.
Natalie, Laura's sister was
an author, poetess, a rebel
and later held literally salons
in Paris for about 60 years.
She was openly gay and her published
book was about lesbian women
with drawings done by her
mother, which caused much grief
for the father who went to Europe
to collect all published copies.
Albert's wife and his two daughters
were following unconventional
lifestyles and was too
much on his health.
He was outraged with
the news of his family
and had the second heart
attack and died in 1902.
The father left his wife
and two daughters a fortune.
Laura returned several more times
to Akka between 1904 and 1906.
And spent weeks and
sometimes months there.
Posing questions to Abdul Baha.
Laura was deepening her
knowledge of the Bahai teachings
and asking deep philosophical
questions.
In 1906 at the request
of Abdul Baha Laura
who was only 27 years old
traveled to Iran, the birth place
of her faith to meet
the Bahai's there.
She was accompanied
by Hippolyte Dreyfus.
Hippolyte Dreyfus was
the first French man
from Paris who had become a Bahai.
Hippolyte had studied law
and had a doctoral degree
and was practicing before
the Paris Court of Appeals.
He later gave up his legal career to
devote himself to oriental studies,
comparative religion and learning
Arabic and Persian intending
to translate the Bahai writings.
Laura also had the chaperone
and escort, a French Bahai lady
who accompanied her on this trip.
They first traveled to Ashgabat in
Turkmenistan where a Bahai House
of Worship was being built.
They met the Bahai's there.
Then they continued on to Iran.
She was the first Western
Bahai woman
and Hippolyte the first
Western Bahai man to visit Iran.
Their stay lasted over
five weeks and most
of the cities they visited had
historical Bahai significance.
In each city they met with
dignitaries, government officials,
prominent people and many
of whom were Bahai's.
Laura said that she was
delighted to meet the crowds.
Upo arrivalin Iran they spent one
night in Vazvan, the birth place
of Tahirih, the Persian Poetess.In
Tehran she met another Iranian
scholar, [Inaudible].
He was originally from Hamadan
and was an Islamic scholar
who had converted to
the Bahai faith.
She spent several days and long
hours engaged in asking questions.
After a grand reception in Tehran,
she wrote "Of course this spiritual
quality and rarified atmosphere
of such Heavenly assemblies were the
distinguished members of the west
and east gathered together in such
a loving environment can neither be
described nor recorded
It should only be seen".
While in Tehran Laura sent a
letter to her mother reassuring her
that she should not worry about her.
Stating that Iran was "one
of the most peaceful
countries that she had seen".
In another letter she wrote that
the Bahai's there were wonderfully
sincere and kind and the people she
met were among the most important
people of Persia.
In Asfahan the delegation
was hosted by [Inaudible],
was the Vazir of Asfahan
with responsibilities
for government finances in that
promise some years earlier.
He was well known to be a Bahai.
[Inaudible] was one of
the notables of Asfahan
who had also become a Bahai.
They arrived in Tabriz
with [Inaudible]
and were welcomed and
greeted by Bahai's.
The governor and the agent
of the crown prince had asked
that a person be present at
every gathering they attended.
His son met with them and
asked them many questions.
He made comments about Ms. Barney's
command of Persian and the fact
that she had no accent
like other foreigners.
And he said that she spoke better
than many educated Iranians.
They also visited Maku, the
city of Maku is well known
in the Bahai history for its fort
where the Bab was imprisoned
for nine months in 1847.
He was later executed by
firing squads in Tabriz.
They had to cut their stay short
because the constitutional
revolution was under way.
She wrote later that
"Many of our brothers
and sisters did not get
a chance to meet us".
Being the first woman from the west,
the first Bahai woman from the west
who visited Iran, her trip
must have opened the minds
of the Iranian women as to what
the western women were doing.
According to the star of the
west a Bahai magazine her journey
to Iran brought much
enthusiasm and passion
to the hearts of the lovers of God.
And Laura Barney's
services in the course
of that visit were
considered distinguished.
Iranians looked up to westerners
and their presence in Iran
in those years must have
been something special
with long-term effect.
Several American newspapers
reported about this trip.
The Washington Herald reported that
"Ms. Barney is a young
woman of many gifts.
And is indulged with
originality and executive talent.
In addition to her
perfect mastery of French,
she has gained vast knowledge
in the Persian language
in which she writes, reads,
translates and speaks fluently.
Her devotion to the Bahai movement
speaks for her broad mindedness
and proves her ardent
desire to serve humanity".
It continued "For this philosophy
she considers an efficient means
to that end.
Her house in Paris has
been a delightful center
and a gathering place
for all those interested
in the higher problems of humanity".
After her return from
Iran she traveled to Akka.
And asked explicit permission from
Abdul Baha to publish her collection
of questions and answers.
The questions were hers from
her Christian perspective,
which she had asked during
her long stays in Akka,
and the answers were by Abdul Baha.
He granted permission after every
page of the book was read, approved
and stamped by his special seal.
The Seal that was used for
his authoritative writings.
And that is why the book that she
compiled became a Bahai Holy Book.
The book that she compiled was
some answered questions in English
and [Inaudible] in Persian and
both were published in 1908.
Some of the topics dealt with the
prophets of God, the soul, fate,
man's destiny, immortality
and life after death.
In this book she also had posed
questions related to Christianity,
such as Birth of Christ,
his resurrection, Baptism
and the Trinity.
Her book became an
essential and significant book
for understanding the basic
belief of the Bahai's.
And introduced this
faith to the west.
It was her greatest accomplishment
and achieved immortal fame
in the Bahai world over.
Laura also collaborated with
Hippolyte to translate the book
into French, which was
also published in 1908.
The book that she had comprised
is translated into 13 languages
and have been reprinted many times.
The last one in 2014.
Soon after that in 1909
she wrote a drama called
"Gods Heroes, a drama in five acts".
And the script was
published the following year.
This was Laura's defensive reaction
to protect the Bahai
faith and the Bab.
It seems that a French
playwright intended to write a play
about the Bab and to have Sarah
Bernhardt the renowned French stage
actress play the role of the
Great Babi Bahai heroine,
the poetess Tahirih.
Tahirih meaning the pure
one, she also had the title
of [Inaudible] consolation
of the eyes.
Who was executed at
the young age in 1852?
Laura was shocked by the
thought of what they would show
on the Paris stage with
the life of the Bab.
That caused her to write this play.
It was written around
the life of Tahirih
and was illuminated
in Persian style.
The protocol among
the theater people was
that if someone was working
on a subject then no
one else would touch it.
Newspapers in the US printed
articles about this publication.
The Boston Globe printed an
article in 1910 with the heading
of "Girl Writes Persian Play
for Parisians" referring
to the political circumstances
in Iran at that time.
It stated "This Persian crisis
has drawn much attention
to the new play written
by an accomplished
and learned American girl,
Ms. Laura Clifford Barney
for the theater the season".
It continued "God's heroes
is a play dealing exclusively
with the modern history of Persia.
The play while dealing with the
modern subject is a Medieval spirit.
It savors of the miracle
or mystery plays,
Ms. Barney knows Persian almost as
well as she knows French or English.
Hence the rich oriental
metaphors one finds in the play
and the flights of
imagination such as our scene
in the [Inaudible]
even the very shades
of meanings are well brought out".
It was in 1911, that Laura
and Hippolyte got married
and they adopted the last
name of Hippolyte Dreyfus.
They had known each other since
1900 and had collaborated together
and had realized that they
had common aspirations.
The same year Abdul Baha who
had been freed and had gone
to Egypt traveled to the
West for the first time.
A trip which Laura
had the major role.
She had invited him and it was her
husband who met him in Marseilles
when he arrived on the
continent of Europe.
Laura and her husband were with
him during his stay in [Inaudible]
in France, a town by Lake Geneva
where he stayed for a few days.
And then they accompanied
him on several side trips.
They accompanied him to
Switzerland and later to England.
In London Lady Blumfield,
Abdul Baha's hostess wrote
"Foremost amongst our visitors were
Monsieur and Madam Dreyfus Barney,
the brilliant French scholar and
his no less brilliant American wife
who spoke Persian with Abdul
Baha, translated for him
and were altogether helpful,
courteous and charming".
When Abdul Baha later traveled to
Paris he stayed in an apartment,
but he spent a good deal of time
at the home of Dreyfus Barney's.
Abdul Baha traveled to
North America in 1912
and visited Washington
D.C. three times.
And the home of Laura's mother
Studio House at least three times.
And addressed the guests there.
Laura accompanied him on
several of his visits during one
of his trips to Washington D.C.
He returned to Paris in January
1913 after his visit in America.
The Dreyfus Barney's again
hosted him at many meetings
and accompanied him
on this trip too.
They were with him with the
Orientalist Edward G. Brown
and his wife visited him.
Laura and Hippolyte
started a trip to regions
of Eastern Asia towards end of 1913.
They visited Japan, Korea and China
and had planned to travel to India,
Persia and back to France.
But while they were in China on
Yenges River World War I broke out
and they were forced to return
to US and then back to Paris.
During the war Laura served
with the American Ambulance Core
which was basically the
American Hospital in Paris.
And Hippolyte assumed
his military obligations
as a member of the French Army.
Laura also volunteered her services
with the Red Cross and helped
with the refugees in several
regions in Southern France.
And she was also the co-founder
of the first Children's
Hospital Avignon.
Laura was made a chevalier of
the French Legion of Honor,
the highest French
decoration created by Napoleon
for her work among the
wounded in World War I.
And later she was promoted
to the Officer
of the French Legion of Honor.
At the end of the war they
visited Abdul Baha before embarking
on their trip that they had cut
short earlier because of the war.
They spent about a year and a half
traveling from Marseilles to Egypt,
Dutch Indies which
is today's Indonesia,
into China they visited
Miramar, Thailand, Cambodia
and Vietnam, Singapore and India.
While in India they had an
audience with Mahatma Gandhi.
And it was in Rangoon Burma
that they heard the news
of the passing of Abdul
Baha in 1921.
After her return Laura became
active with the League of Nations.
The predecessor of
the United Nations.
The League of Nations was the first
international organization whose
principle mission was
to maintain world peace.
She chose to work in social
and humanitarian arenas in line
with the principles
she had accepted.
She also became an active member of
the International Council of Women
and was its representative at the
League of Nations for almost all
of her - the remainder of her life.
Having seen the horrors
of war firsthand she said
"In a way all these
horrors are a good thing
for the future generations.
Who see what war means.
Not simply chivalry and medals.
I think that women will
be great help to get
out of this horrible
habit of the past".
Laura lost her husband
Hippolyte in 1928.
She was not yet 50 years
old when she became a widow
and they had no children.
She lost her mother
a few years later.
She organized an annual
exhibition of her mother's art work
in Washington D.C. and the First
Lady Eleanor Roosevelt attended the
exhibition opening.
She also established a
memorial fund and a trust
in the name of her mother.
And donated her paintings
to museums mostly
to the Smithsonian
Museum of American Art.
For the remainder of her life.
She rendered many services
with numerous responsibilities.
One of her responsibilities
in those years was serving
on the International Committee
on intellectual corporation.
A committee that was the
precursor of [Inaudible].
Some of the distinguished
people who had worked
with this committee were
Albert Einstein, Marie Currie,
Henry Berksen, Bella Bartuke,
Thelma Mann and many others.
She was also the vice president
of disarmament committee
which was formed by 14 major
international women organizations
working tirelessly with the
League of Nations which was active
in Geneva up to the
start of World War II.
In the 1930's Laura
traveled across Canada
and gave talks at several
major cities.
She was invited also to
visit Egypt, Lebanon, Syria,
Turkey and Greece and gave talks.
As a brilliant speaker she
gave her talks at universities,
national libraries and clubs,
talking about peace, disarmament
and bringing people of
different cultures together.
One newspaper reporter
wrote about her.
It was she, the American woman
transplanted to France who was able
to put her roots down there
to serve a greater homeland.
That of men of good will
whose prestigious adventures
of the spirit I wanted to know.
Then the reporter continued,
"Madam Dreyfus Barney's
astonishing personality
and her lucid intelligence
are self-evident".
I admired this elite woman who knows
how to think globally at a time
when so much hatred and so many
minds make brothers into enemies
and once again the
threat of war returns.
Another newspaper article stated
"Madam Dreyfus Barney
teaches by example".
Are not the very tone of
her advocacy the nature
of her arguments the
very proof of this?
As an American woman
a quarter Jewish,
and Dreyfus as her
families last name,
her husband's family name she
was encouraged to leave France
at the onset of World War II.
She traveled to Washington D.C. in
1940 and stayed here for six years.
Upon her arrival after visiting
a photography exhibition
at the Library of Congress,
she wrote an article titled
"In a Library" reflecting
on the war.
She wrote "During this cruel period
we know that we must remain united
in our services to others.
Then the end of the war will find
us strong before the realities
of life".
During those six years in
the US she remained active.
She served on several national
and international boards.
She became the co-founder of the
Institute of War Organization,
a permanent center in Washington
for the study and dissemination
of the principles and
methods of world organization.
It was sponsored by a group of
distinguished men and women known
for their interests in
international affairs.
More than 20 of whom
were representatives
of universities throughout
the country.
That same year Laura
Barney served as a member
of the United States Delegation to
the conference of the commission
of intellectual corporation
held in Havana, Cuba.
Laura was invited to attend the
international congress of women
that was taking place
in Iran in 1967.
She was invited by the sister of
the Shah who was the vice president
of the International Council
of Women at that time.
Laura was very interested
to return to Iran
but her health did not allow her.
She was 81years old at the time.
She stayed active until
the end of her life.
In her later years her mind was
still sharp even though her body was
handicapped by rheumatism and
the side effects of a fall
from a horse during her
childhood that had stayed with her
and caused her to limp all her life.
Laura died in August 1974
in Paris at the age of 94.
And according to her wishes
she was buried in the same plot
as her sister Natalie
in the cemetery.
The two sisters had selected
different paths in life
from early on, but Laura
remained devoted and close
to her sister despite
their differences.
Newspapers on both sides of the
Atlantic such as the Herald Tribune,
the New York Times,
the Washington Post,
Lamond and Le Figero
announced her death.
Someone who knew Laura Barney well
wrote, "With her keen intelligence,
logical mind and investigative
nature she devoted her whole life
from adolescence to improving
human relations bringing people
of the different races,
classes and nations together".
He continued, "Those who had the
rare privilege of knowing her
over a period of many decades can
testify that her on daunted zeal
for the objective of brotherhood
of man remained alive and glowing
to the very last day
of her life on earth".
Laura Dreyfus Barney challenged
many of her immediate social circles
and selected a path different
from what her social
milieu would have dictated.
She could have selected a
much easier path in life,
but she had an intense attraction
to the teachings that
had come from Iran.
She had said "But he
has told us not to keep
to ourselves alone what he has
entrusted to us for humanity".
This is a glimpse into the life
of a privileged American woman
who followed the teachings of
a spiritual leader from Iran.
She tried to bring the
world closer together,
helped create mutual understanding
and not only between the people
of the west and the east,
but the rest of the world
and devoted her life to
humanitarian activities.
Thank you very much for
your patience and thank you
for giving me this opportunity
to share with you some parts
of my research, and to
talk about one aspect
of Laura Dreyfus Barney's life
that of her connections
with Iran and Iranians.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you Mona.
Thank you everyone for being
here especially on a lunch break.
I also want to take a second
and ask Mona to say something
about the books she
brought in as well.
>> Mona Khademi: The books
I brought are her books
that have been published.
There are some answered
questions in English, in Persian
and God's Heroes, a Drama in
Five Acts the 1910 print of it.
>> Thank you.
We have time for some questions,
feel free to ask and I will be glad
to repeat them in the microphone.
[ Inaudible question ]
>> Before discovering the house
had you had heard of Laura before?
>> Mona Khademi: Yes I
knew that she was a Bahai
and I knew she had written a book.
But that was basically what I knew.
I didn't know much about her mother,
whether she was a Bahai or not.
I don't - I didn't know any
details of her life at the time.
Thank you.
>> Any other questions?
Don't be shy.
>> Thank you everyone.
[ Inaudible question ]
>> What was the most
attractive thing to her,
to the Bahai faith for her?
>> Mona Khademi: You know I
think I mentioned it in my talk,
I think the activities that she
picked up for rest of her life
and she devoted her time to it,
maybe those were what attracted her
to - what was she attracted to.
The equality of men and women.
She believed in that
from the beginning
and also the fact that
humanity is one.
That is one of the main
principles of the Bahai faith
and she devoted all her
life to those two causes.
Through the League of Nations and
the International Council of Women.
>> Go ahead.
[ Inaudible question ]
>> Did she leave any
written material
about her observations
from her visits to Iran?
>> Mona Khademi: You know she left
Paris at the start of World War II.
She was in America for six years.
When she returned to Paris
many things were stolen
from her apartment, including her
notes and diaries of her visits
to Akka, meetings with Abdul
Baha, many material belongings
but she said that the most important
were her notes of all those years
that she wanted to publish
and she had already asked
for permission to publish.
Those were all stolen, so whatever
I have found is through her letters
to other family members, to
her sister or to her mother.
I refer to some of them in my talk.
But nothing else written with
details of her trip to Iran.
[ Inaudible question ]
>> Compilation of her public talks?
>> Mona Khademi: There
is no compilation
but I do have some of them.
I have seen some of her talks.
That requires further research
because as I said she traveled
across Canada, she traveled in
many Middle Eastern Countries
and gave talks, one needs
to do further research going
into either archives
of those countries
or through the organization
that she traveled
with to find the transcript
of those talks.
[ Inaudible question ]
>> Mona Khademi: You know
since I've started my research
in the year 2000 I have given
talks and published some papers
and even a chapter of a book.
Right now I am working on
a full biography of hers,
which is two-thirds done and
I hope that will be out and in
that book I speak in more detail
about her other activities
like the International Council
of Women and the different roles
and responsibilities she had
with the League of Nations.
>> Wonderful.
Again thank you very much.
I want to say that
Mary-Jane and Joan had to step
out because they had
another meeting to attend to.
But are very grateful
to have you here.
Thank you very much for coming and
look forward to seeing you soon.
The next program is
October 19 on the Genesis
of Printing in Afghanistan.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.